July 2025 Thailand's F-16 fighter jets
bomb Cambodian positions, the first use
of air power in this border
conflict since the Cold War.
The target 4.6 square kilometers, roughly
650 football fields.
By July 28th, 38 dead, 140,000 evacuated,
an 8-year-old boy
killed at a gas station.
Both sides blame a French map from 1908.
This isn't ancient
history suddenly exploding.
This is calculated modern politics.
Cambodia's new prime minister, Hun Manet,
took power in 2023 after
his father's 38-year rule.
He needs nationalist credentials.
Thailand just
experienced political chaos.
Their prime minister, removed by
Constitutional Court,
Constitutional Court
weeks before the fighting.
Independent satellite
analysis tells the real story.
Cambodia was responsible
for 33 skeletal actions.
Thailand for 14.
Cambodia faces serious
domestic problems right now.
Human trafficking compounds, cyber scam
operations and economic struggles.
Thailand's dealing with
political instability.
Border nationalism gives both governments
something more valuable
than the actual territory.
Legitimacy.
When Thai Major General Boon-sin declared
"the temple is ours and we must take it
back", he wasn't
responding to colonial injustice.
He was performing nationalist theater
that justifies military budgets and
distracts from failures at home.
Here's what makes
this particularly cruel.
There are farmers living
in that disputed 4.6 km2.
4.6 square kilometers.
They can't get land
titles from either government.
If they build a house, one country calls
it illegal construction.
If they cross their own rice paddy, the
other side might arrest
them for border violation.
Thousands of people
trapped in permanent legal limbo.
Modern GPS technology could resolve the
border ambiguity in weeks.
The Joint Boundary Commission
successfully marked 603
of the 798 km by 2012.
Then it stalled.
Not because they can't figure out where
the border should be.
Because both
governments prefer the ambiguity.
So why does a map from
1908 give them this tool?
Let's go back.
The Franko-Saimi Treaty of 1904
established a clear border principle.
Follow the watershed line
in the Dangrag Mountains.
A watershed is simple. It's where water
drains to different rivers.
Water flows one direction towards
Cambodia and the other towards Thailand.
The temple of Preah Viher
sits atop a dramatic cliff.
Water drains northward into Thailand.
By the treaty's own terms, the temple
should be Thai territory.
In 1907, a joint French-Saimi's
commission was
established to map this border.
They worked together in the field.
Then the commission
disbanded, months before finishing.
No final maps were
ever officially approved.
The French didn't care.
Their cartographers produced
maps anyway, working alone.
In August 1908, they published Annex 1.
The border line curved northward around
the temple promontory,
placing it in French Indochina.
The deviation from the watershed was
visible to anyone who looked.
They sent 50 copies to Bangkok.
Prince Dhamrong,
Prince Dhamrong, Thailand's interior
Thailand's interior minister,
minister, tanked France
tanked France and requested more copies.
They were distributed
to embassies worldwide.
160 complete sets.
For 50 years, Siam said nothing.
When Thailand, Siam's successor state,
finally objected in
finally objected in 1958,
1958, the International Court
the International Court
of Justice ruled they were
"procluded by their
conduct from denying acceptance".
their conduct from denying acceptance.
The treaty specified the watershed.
The French violated it.
But Thailand's silence meant the colonial
map error became permanent,
permanent, binding international
binding international law.
The 1962 ICJ ruling
gave Cambodia the temple.
temple, but deliberately
But deliberately avoided
defining the actual border line.
Thailand claimed only the
temple structures counted.
Cambodia wanted the entire promontory.
The 2013 clarification expanded the area,
but still refused to draw a clear border.
That ambiguity was gold
for modern politicians.
This isn't unique to
Cambodia and Thailand.
Approximately 195 active
territorial disputes worldwide
disputes worldwide traced
traced directly to
colonial era mapping decisions.
That's 500 million people living in
contested borderlands.
European Enlightenment mapmaking claimed
scientific precision.
Theodolites,
triangulation, topographic surveys.
But this precision was selective.
Colonial powers subordinated treaty
principles to imperial interests,
interests, creating maps with
creating maps with enough technical
authority to bind nations to acceptance.
acceptance, but enough ambiguity to
But enough ambiguity to fuel
international
disputes for over a century.
The French cartographers who drew that
line in 1908 are long dead.
The Siamese officials who accepted it
have been dust for decades.
But people are still dying because modern
states find this ambiguity
ambiguity more politically
more politically viable than resolution.
viable than resolution.
The eight-year-old boy killed at a gas
station in July 2025
station in July 2025 died
died because of decisions made before his
great-great grandparents were born.
But more honestly, he died because
politicians in Phnom Penh and Bangkok
found his death useful.
Colonial cartography
didn't just draw bad borders.
draw bad borders, it
It created the permanent
machinery for conflict.
When domestic politics needed
distraction, when leaders need
nationalist credentials,
when military budgets need justification,
the ambiguous border
the ambiguous border is
right there, ready to weaponize.
The question isn't whether French
colonial maps were wrong.
colonial maps were wrong, they were.
They were.
The question isn't whether modern
technology could fix this.
this, it could in weeks.
It could in weeks.
The real question is this.
Do these disputes persist
because they can't be resolved?
can't be resolved, or
Or because powerful interests
prefer they remain unresolved?
If you want to understand how colonial
history shapes modern
conflicts, start there.
Not with the map makers from 1908, but
with the politicians from 2025,
from 2025 who choose, every
who choose, every single day, to keep
those maps ambiguous.
Subscribe for more
evidence-based myth-busting.